PEGI 12
attention Admirals welcome to
battlefleet gothic the new space RTS set
in the Warhammer 40k universe as chaos
forces are making a breakthrough in the
Gothic sector it is time to introduce
you to the ship so will compose your
fleet in the upcoming battle against
Abaddon the Despoiler from the smallest
of our sword class frigates to the
larger Imperia class battleships the
Imperium Navy fields the staple of
mankind's technology frigates and
destroyers light cruisers cruisers and
battle cruisers and finally battleships
these vessels may not be the fastest but
they all embark serious firepower along
with strong voice shields and thick
armor millennia of war against the
countless enemies such as a traitor
legions orcs and the elder toward the
Imperium to be versatile and so your
ships allow quick adaptation to any kind
of encounter or battle situation your
targets will be shredded by your barrage
of torpedo strikes or if your ships are
equipped devastating overcolor blasts
your powerful broadside armament and
micro cannons and large batteries will
make sure
the survivors as a last resort
remember these ships are well armored
and can take quite a beating
this means that ramming your prow into
the hull of an enemy ship can be a
surprisingly effective tactic especially
if your target is of a smaller class
your ship's warp drives can also be
upgraded to achieve microwarp jumps use
this to your advantage either to quickly
get out of harm's way or to catch up
with the fleeting enemy or to Surprise
them by setting your ship on a collision
course
battlefleet gothic Armada warps in on PC
beginning of 2016
dismissed
Oh